yeah are you recording now yeah we're
recording now yeah yeah we are don't
tell me when we are you're live bro what
are you drinking your stupid mug what's
that mother and there's some coffee in
here don't you have some sort of intro
or something then we have to sit through
18 that's no dude we'd already hate that
will its Will Sasso done hi I'm will
sasso yeah how can need for the program
I am welcome to the program
I watched you Ryan yeah I mean it's
great to be on the fighter and the kid
as you know more importantly as your
audience knows there's a deep connection
between me and your audience this has
been going on for years ever since I won
the first guest of the air right through
all right bye
you did win and now since it's been
rigged and I've been left off of that
thing every [ __ ] year whatever
I've decided even though I don't give a
[ __ ] because I have this well I give a
[ __ ] about your audience and because I
have this relationship in the audience I
think it's time that I made myself the
peoples champ WWE World Championship
buddy Chris Fowler from back home gave
me that it's pretty cool well brain
jealous but you can't just name yourself
the People's Champ I mean that's kind of
like you know it sees a little obnoxious
and you're acting puzzled now I can see
on your stupid face yeah but but this is
something again I know it's the podcast
yeah is between me and the people okay
well but you haven't think why we call
it that's why we call me the people [ __ ]
okay job sling that thing over your
shoulder like that well well is that the
same thing the rock did is am I right on
that yeah it might be a little gimmick
infringement from the rock he did call
himself the People's Champ just want to
go like that just want to make sure this
is for everyone making memes at home
ready that's good yeah that's good
that's good
go ahead okay another thing I want to
talk about is I want to congratulate you
guys on your format change well what
does that mean what do you mean what do
you mean well we didn't even log in I'm
congratulating you so obviously you know
about the format change well here goes
some more liquid in your [ __ ] face
and so that was you'll stop drinking
yeah now you keep drinking is not fair
come May 15th we're we're at it we're at
it with the with the ten minute podcast
now I'm gonna rough you up a little bit
will so you might mess up you up so it's
but I'm gonna rough you up for this
you're getting buff dude now I'm gonna
be jerking off in the corner do you know
Brandon are you familiar with you know
when it comes to the People's Champ and
wrestling in this whole thing are you
are you are you you're familiar with the
[ __ ] comeback someone get in there
fair at the end of the match yeah sure
man yeah doing that whole thing yeah and
pointing in okay so you better be
careful because if you beat the living
snot out of me I'm gonna haul up and
then you're gonna have to stop for me
okay you're gonna have to you're gonna
jump a little bit when I slam you and
when I [ __ ] drop the elbow you're
gonna go hey will that's a good story
that's a that's a good story new source
hey well did you did you see the WB try
and WrestleMania with no crowd I know I
know you're big Russell fan I know this
how embarrassing is it with no crowd it
was it was it was a long thing to do
some would say the most wrong thing to
do well yeah theme of today yes the
wrong thing to do and one of the
wrongest things to do I could i watch
less of that than I listen to Brian on
that military pump it made it made no
sense it made no sense it was like
watching your cousin's play fight in the
basement yeah it was so awkward it's
it's weird to watch grown men do that
it's very weird it's an indictment of
the art form yeah cuz I'll call it an
art form but I'll also make this face
because when you if you learn it without
a bunch of people are gonna lose it's
like well what is it it's just some
people rolling around in a way that
they've already planned okay right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]